molti di voi ragazzi soprattutto quelli
che mi conoscono da più tempo sanno che
io ogni tot faccio un momenti epici di
tutto ciò che mi è successo durante
l'anno insomma era un po che non facevo
momenti epici dei blog quindi un insieme
delle scene migliori dei blog che sono
usciti durante l'anno ha sorpreso
l'assenza speciale
ve l'ho tirato fuori oggi iscrivetevi
mettete like condividete con tutti i
vostri amici o non ne farò mai più in
tutta la mia vita
sto scherzando però fatelo veloci
eccolo eccolo celebrità sembrava allora
molto bravo parliamo di shampoo invece
che dice
ed ecco che queste cambiati porta
e mi serviva a fare questa ripresa per
fare la copertina del video e fare un po
di più bene
no
adesso perché poi quando totti non è che
guardini guarda dritto come se stessimo
parlando di me montaio manolo valido va
introdotta vuoi diventare invisibile per
un capriccio ogni volta che tu fai che
lo fai tu ca nun si restringe di un
millimetro tranquilla anzi che tanto
possiamo respingerli con dove sarà
sempre abbastanza
[Musica]
la mia gagna detrazione so che ci siamo
sempre entrare nella bocca di ferocia di
una barca è possibile prendere questo
pulsante home ha mai il vostro cane
gatto mai ha subito sì perché da non
c'avevo bella neanche il mio cane molto
alti tempo che però schiacciato scusa
come l'accesso a settembre mostro ha
messo settembre o mio dio non ho il
biglietto come passo è un hacker
gismonti il controllo bagagli ragazzi mi
sa che quello è morto morto proprio lei
va beh come si chiama il miglior amico
peloso del protagonista di solo e star
wars story non lo so ci becca questo il
lama meccanico
vai
[Risate]
prima inquadratura sui culi giustamente
random l'altro ragazzo scende
incoraggiato manco fosse il rocky balboa
si svita anche lui le braccia
[Musica]
entrate in pubblico ma da qui al vinile
che ho preparato per questo
vabbè se va male youtube cerco di
imparare come si può lo stuntman partita
malissimo
ora che ti striscia madonna che male
highroad ore sempre bene ci ha detto no
grazie
giuro che se non ho capito male antico
fuma un sacco altre persone odore lordo
a voi credo che sia la roba che da altre
persone puzzino ma questo succede
comunque stessimo un agente boots noto a
tutti che
[Musica]
[Applauso]
abbiamo capito basta smontato il braccio
ma chi sono questi
chi cazzo sono questi sono altre persone
non c'entrano non era facevano parte
della gang ma cos'è un virus
no no ti denuncio ho denunciato per
molto meno
vabbè che maschili come fai schifo
questo lo zaino dell'anno prossimo di fa
vj che puoi cambiare la toppa che lo
straffi e ci sono le toppe c'è rosa c'è
azzurro c'è nero lo metti qua e pam e
chiara ferragni chi siamo io che ecco
che è venuto a trovarmi ciao ciao
c'è selena adesso ve la faccio vedere
eccola selena charles elena e poi c'è
lui è tornato è tornato quel figlio di
manu chao
oggi vi daremo dimostrazione di come si
fa allenamento quando va in vacanza
ovviamente il mio personal trainer
sarebbe molto fiero di questo venite con
me e tutto questo ragazzi speriamo non
ci rubino le bici ne puoi piu di meo a
quanto 6 9 10 l'undicesimo per gli
iscritti il dodicesimo il dodicesimo mai
facci vedere uomo mentre le faccio una
stretta sul suo zaino tutti i palestrati
lo comprino perché merita 6 a 3 o 3 o 4
beh non male un amo tantissimo tanto
tanto è un segno d'affetto cioè parole
d'affetto poesie d'amore pablo neruda
chi
mi sono quello che si nota
[Musica]
moda per ballare questa musica basta che
vai di quella mano il suo milan destra
infatti a tempo
[Musica]
hybris
ma incredibilmente bravo a scrivere
musica ma diventi sorda ecco questo
potrebbe interessarsi chiederà sordo e
cieco cavalca non lo so sempre dove
aspetta solo di 99 il tenore sordo
musica per tanti bidoni mozart ma ad
alta qualità il cazzo di mozart ma
zardetto ghiera a vista parlamento però
arriva ora dico mi sveglio e adesso ecco
ecco mi metti a cipriani larghe tese
fumata
la vendita gli uomini che frequenti
tanto azzardata da me tocca ti denuncio
me non ti avvicinare un quella roba è
ma che cazzo
[Musica]
ma che schifo fario ho intervistato
steven spielberg e secondo voi quale
domanda potrò mai aver fatto male miss
fa vigente many people isoli meglio
queste una pasticca beni comuni spazio
dei ai making di frank west in apple
peace games and what do you think about
it and why i am inn chartering miur
mobili giocherei mai ma se la zeki sera
sul palco in mutande ma direi 45 milioni
facciamo stasera sul palco in muta
parliamo dei licheni i geni delle
montagne saranno rari o saranno
gironzolando licheni surez che jean a
come si chiama
si chiama macchia trance macchia quello
sono io quello che è morto ma quello fa
tornare in realtà ragazza
ragazzi se volete fare cosplay
particolari di alcuni personaggi disney
che va da me ma come romanista ciao raga
suoli questo era il video dell'anno di
momenti epici è stato mano fighissimo
per il blog in realtà c'è un sacco di
cose sono successe spero che l'anno
prossimo sia ancora meglio se volete
vedere altre scene così belle perché
siete buongustai iscrivetevi al canale
se volete sapere quando vescovi video
essere super aggiornati sulle cose che
faccio schiacciate alla campanella a
quella che sta sotto il vicino alla
scritta iscriviti quanto è complicato il
mondo della tecnologia schiacciate st
campana maledetta e vi arrivano le
notifiche di quando metto un video bello
io ragazzi sopravvivere se ci sono
società che è riuscita come mi piace che
le ricerche di potenziare sono stati
questi siete e noi ci vediamo come
sempre ai ragazzi
[Musica]